[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to be talking about
conscious reality creating we have Rick
Parrish joining us on the show hello hey
thank you so much for coming I'm super
excited also huge shout out to Andrew
Thompson for introducing us
I'm super excited to talk to you Rick
Rick Pierce is the founder of the Paris
principle which helps you use your
dreams trauma drama and chaos as a
vehicle for transformation so that you
can create the reality you desire you
can find the links in the bio below to
conscious reality creator calm the Paris
principle calm as well as Rick's
LinkedIn profile okay Rick let's start
things off by asking you what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
well the direction of the world is
awesome it's you know for me because
I've been outside of this paradigm and
coming back to it I understand deeply
and profoundly where we are and the more
chaos you have the more potential you
have for change right so the null
paradigm is dying it's it's already dead
it's just in the throes of its
experience and so with that death
becomes a lot of chaos and you know the
Mayans predicted is lots of people
predicted this was going to be going on
the reason that the calendars don't
continue is because there was a very
specific humanity has never had the
chance to supersede itself it's always
in a natural order of things and it's
the planets go around everybody you know
you go through a natural process of
synthesis that's always happening and
human beings have been growing and
evolving along that once a human being
understands that it's conscious of
itself it can interrupt that pattern you
see they couldn't do that before
now that humanity is going for
a state of adolescence - a state of
spiritual adulthood which it's
struggling with that right now because
people don't know what it takes to be an
adult they're really adaptive
adolescence as you can see by the news
and you can see by the political arenas
in the geopolitical arenas it's like a
really bad day at high school and that's
happening because that paradigm cannot
sustain itself anymore and it's breaking
but we don't have another one and
conscious reality creation is
understanding there's something that
I've got to define there's something
over here I've got it defined so I have
a place to let go and a place to attach
and that's got to be conscious in order
to drop that so it's in a beautiful
place I mean it's like when a woman goes
into labor her temperature goes up her
metabolism goes up the earth is going up
because it's making room for us we're
the pinnacle of nature we're not a
problem we're not it is making room for
us to be more conscious so the weather
and these things are changin but the
weather and everything is reflecting our
own internal state those patterns that
have always existed and always moved are
changing and so the state of the world
although chaotic and it's in the best
place that's ever been and it's going to
continue to get better for some for some
people it's going to continue to get
worse because that dichotomy that you're
seeing is the same problem that inner
adolescent has I don't want gray it's
good or bad just give it to me good or
bad so I can figure out what's going on
and make my choices and get out of here
and move on to something else that's
better
that's the adolescent so that particular
mindset is ended and so what's happening
is you're saying pro-life pro-choice
right wing left wing this that and but
everybody's arguing about the same
stupid things because they really don't
know what they're arguing for there's no
set of values there's no structure
underneath that these since the
adolescent changes its mind depending on
what's going on one thing they're
arguing for today they're arguing
against tomorrow because they really
don't understand the core value of
what's being expressed in America for
instance our our Constitution is
freedom and security elevating those two
things that's why you have an eagle with
arrows in one hand and peace and the
other hand but in their talons because
the Eagle represents responsibility I
can go left or right what do you want to
do what's going to happen here and I can
go either way it's like America needs to
be free in order to breathe and see
right now all this major control from
this adolescent mindset is trying to
inhibit where some people are dying to
be more free and other people are dying
to be less free because they're worried
about security and since America is
specifically specifically written by
alchemists knowing that there has to be
a push-pull in place for things to move
harmony is a static state
you don't want harmony you only want to
go in and out of harmony that's what a
conscious person does I need to create
some chaos in order to create some
change and then get back to a new
harmony and what does that do to my next
chaos that's the breathing in and out
right and so in our system we what is it
we want security want freedom
you've got to dance between that all the
time if you go too far one direction too
much freedom is tyranny too much control
is a complete it's the antithesis to
love freedom and creativity the
antithesis to that is control the thing
that makes America great their
creativity their freedom and the love
that they have while you're going to
control that's what you have to give up
so the adolescent cannot do that yeah
well isn't cannot balance that because
they don't have a set that they're
standing on are the ones that my mom and
dad in my school and my government told
me so the world is in a fantastic place
it's just not for the adolescent it's
not but for the adult it's badass
yeah the the big history perspective
that you take there with understanding
how it's actually been a multi ten tens
of thousands of year process of where we
are consciously evolving now to be
potentially at the pinnacle core of our
evolution and there's now more and more
space on the planet for these for the
people to be birthed into the eight
billion that are alive right now playing
on
please superbowl that's why there's
eight billion people here everybody
wants to see what are we doing with this
consciousness and most people are
spectators they're not going to be
leaders in this because they're still
arguing about the wrong things until
they recognize like this is about
getting along and finding not a
compromise that's what the adolescent
does the adult finds both of our
preferences need to be met and we'll
both enjoy the process if we both make a
compromise we both don't get what we
want and there's no fulfillment in the
process you see the adolescent doesn't
know how to do that you can get eight
billion people to all get what they want
sure yeah yeah we gotta imagine it it
yeah first you've got to know it's
possible and then you've got to be able
to go for it right I mean of course
that'd take a tremendous amount of what
am I saying
to take a tremendous amount of patience
but the thing is the journey is how you
get there what would it be like if we
all decided we wanted eight million
people to agree on something on their
preference see right now that's not even
an idea it's not even a conversation
because they're in another paradigm of a
limit limit of a limited paradigm belief
and then also the the notion of the
adolescent how the adolescent wants
either a black or white instead of
degraded yeah yes that was another
interesting one Rick let's learn more
about your journey you're born in Castro
Valley and then you've been practicing
shaman for 28 years and also you had
this crazy accident down in Los Angeles
trian accident we are three and that
kind of transformed your life with a
death experience so yeah teach us about
this it
it it transformed my life for sure my
life I already considered myself an
enlightened person before I died and
there were some very key elements that I
had understood that I didn't really
understand the profound nature of what I
was thinking and what I was experiencing
before I died but it hadn't it's the way
I got back is what I was doing before I
died that enabled me to reincarnate
myself all human beings are going to
learn how to do this because the old way
is to forget and come back forget and
come back and try to remember and forget
and come back and try to remember once
you become conscious you can actually
interrupt that pattern but you have to
become conscious first so humanity had
to evolve to a certain place and of
course there's always people on the
front of the bell curve I am one of
those people on the front of the bell
curve I know what I'm doing I know how
I'm doing it I know why I'm doing it I
know why I'm here I know when to engage
you and not to engage passionately so
part of part of what happened was
I had incorporated lets us say I
understood that belief preceded
experience that was a very profound
thing that I had learned that I had been
incorporating for it at least a decade
really going like wow my beliefs are
what I'm seeing the way your beliefs
create reality most people say no the
reason that I I come up to this
conclusion and this has happened to me
10 times now so that's why I don't trust
anybody that's why I do what I do know
the belief actually has been generating
that 10 times you're supposed to take
that and recognize I'm stuck in the past
on this pattern and this pattern is
continuing until I can pull the function
form follows function physical reality
follows a function and the function is a
belief form follows function form
follows a belief so once you once you
really get into that start you become a
person who is 100% self author like when
I used to work with couples I would tell
people it's not 50/50 it's 100 100 you
had to be 100% responsible for the
relationship not well I did this and
they didn't do that and I'm doing this
and I'm growing and you're not growing
and no no you need to be 100% that
choice with your relationship and the
person the other person it's not your
business
what they're how they're doing or what
they're not doing your job is to love
them or or just don't get in a
relationship well I mean you can love a
dog pads you can love this yeah
but see when you become a conscious
reality creator intimacy is a key part
of creating reality because intimacy is
where all the deep feelings come from
and reality is an expression of your
emotional state oh that's so icky
yeah well for the adolescent it
certainly is because the adolescent gets
scared this is going to be painful I'm
gonna be feeling all kinds of stuff that
I've taken a lot of time covering up
thank you very much and I don't care to
bring it up again but that reality it's
like throwing away any time you separate
from physical reality or separate from
an mo
you'll experience you have no power to
alter it anymore because I have
separated myself and a negative judgment
and now I have no responsibility left in
it so I can't alter that reality now
that I've negative judged it
so if intimacy out of all that surround
us it's a reflection of our unconscious
mind every single thing that you observe
in reality that is not conscious is a
reflection of your unconscious mind now
if all of this is part of my unconscious
mind how am I going to discern what's
something I want to care about think
about get involved with versus all the
things that I could react to in this
experience it's going to be intimacy
intimacy is going to be able to teach
you whether you're intimate with a dog
with a business with a person you must
be intimate in order to get a positive
feedback mechanism operating in physical
reality so the adolescent is not being
intimate because they got hurt so bad
once they don't ever want to love like
that again I don't ever want to feel out
of control like that again so for most
people that are wounded adolescent
trying to find a relationship so they
end up creating controlling it in a way
that I'm not going to get hurt I need
this I need an open relationship and I
need you to do this and I need that and
instead of being a loving person you're
trying to get love which is the child
ego there you go in the child is am I
getting enough no you never get enough
as a child is the adolescent am I good
enough no you're never good enough as an
adolescent only adult has the
opportunity to be good enough and have
enough you see you have to move into
that but anyway that accident basically
put me outside of the space and time you
see whenever you hear a near-death
experience the person is always framing
in the physical I was walking around the
hospital nobody could see me and I was
out of pain and it was amazing and I
could go anywhere in the world I wanted
to go it's because you've arrived to
systems you have outside of space and
time and you have space and time and a
near-death is you're in the liminal in
between the two so you're taking on some
characteristics of not being physical
that I could do and think and do
anything I want but I'm framing
everything in the physical that's
because you're in between when you
actually die you
that whole experience in you back on the
other side whatever you want to call it
the minute that you leave physical
experience
there's no universe left and matter of
fact this is what tripped me out the
most was I have to explain it with words
it's but just this is all metaphorical
but the actual universe was literally
the size of maybe a grapefruit and when
I looked at it I could see there were
millions of universes in that space
that's called physicality so that's how
big you really are is all the universes
there could be all the possibility is
still a defined space within physicality
outside of space and time so it's almost
like you have a little ball rolling
around your living room and there's your
physical experience whatever you want to
do but what happened was because I had
such a profound experience of
understanding how the mechanism was
working I mean I really understood it
but I didn't know I understood it so
well and when I died and left I could
see what happened was until you become
conscious in a physical experience you
don't have an anchor in the physical to
come back to the same lifetime twice in
a way you appear that if you walked say
you're about to go it you're in the
causal plane you're pre your very
physical and you're about to get
physical at that moment you're making
the choices that you want to experience
here you have to set a framework because
possibility if you jumped in here into
possibility you would split up in a
million pieces so fast you wouldn't be
able to frame anything so you create
your universe before you get here you
choose your astrological sign your
anagram you choose some you choose a lot
of things in order to contextualize
possibility so when you enter that when
you before you enter you just see an
ocean of possibility and every ripple is
a different lifetime every ripple is not
linear it's anywhere you want to go at
any particular time and lifetimes are
not linear that's what we do with them
out here so when you see that from the
outside and you've had a profound
awakened experience when you dip back
into what physical experiences you'll
see a tsunami on the ocean and you're
like that's the wave I woke up
and now you can re-anchor back and
that's how I got back I knew that
lifetime I could recognize it where it
stood up like I woke up I didn't have to
be physical anymore I understood what
physicality was I understood how to
manipulate it positive in the positive
sense manipulation and I was doing it
and so when I got out I was like well
look time and space is thing I see where
I could go back
why what's and see when you're outside
of space and time anything that you can
frame a question the answer is in your
mind it's like you are Google when
you're not here so I thought I was gone
for five years like it felt like five
year because you don't have time but it
felt like five years at first I was
freaking out I was like five five years
five years oh it's gonna be weird like I
was thinking all this stuff was like
what am I talking about there's these
conversations going on in my head that I
didn't even understand what was
happening because I was panicking
because even when I came back into
physical I came back through knew what I
was doing knew how to heal myself like I
learned I was like okay if I'm gonna go
back I need to know how to get back in
my body clearly how do I get back in my
body how do I do that and so I was
asking all these questions and I was
gone for a long time when you come back
into physical realities it's very
disconcerning because all of a sudden
you have all that your is to know inside
of you and you're going down to a pea
and the grain of sand on the beach
you can't hold who you are and so while
you're coming back I'm panicking because
I can just feel all the information
leaving me but at the same time I was
like could hear a voice know you know
don't worry don't worry you you know
what to do and so I came back and I
could see my body was on the ground and
I was listening to everybody and I was
doing I was like this is the near-death
thing I'm fine do anything I was this is
cool
but I wasn't hurting everything was
great right and I was like okay my body
was all tweaked up on the sidewalk and
it was covered up and it was bloody and
I was like oh I was like nope nope nope
I know what to do I had already felt
like I forgot a lot but I still felt
very powerful because I was in between
so that I knew what to do so I got back
in my body for instance just in case
you're ever out of your body and you
know that you're in the liminal the way
that you get back in your body is you
have to make a choice a very intentional
choice and when you make that choice you
must take a deep breath because that's
the responsibility playing out in the
physical and you outside of physical it
puts you right back like immediately so
if you're like in a coma or something
and you're stuck you you can get back in
you just have to know that it's in a
very willful choice has to be made as
soon as I did that I was back in my body
and then I was like like massive from
zero to a hundred points of pain and I
was just like no like oh my god he's
alive and they come running back over
and my shirt was open and the EMT was a
woman and she reached over and her hair
went across my channel I hunted razor
blades just sliced my chest I just
screamed oh my god
and I looked and I was like [ __ ]
something's wrong that's her hair and
then she put the blood pressure thing
and I started pulling I felt I started
crying it was breaking my arm and I was
like get it off get it off get it off
get away from me get the [ __ ] away from
me don't touch me don't just leave me
alone
and like sir I said I know I just
happened I know what just happened to me
okay but you got to leave me alone I'm
gonna close my eyes for a few minutes
and nothing's wrong don't touch me I
need to think and I went back there
nothing yelling might hit higher self
like I need help I'm freaking out right
now I'm in a meditation and I'm like and
then I got that voice like you know what
to do just do what you know what to do
and I was like just be in charge and I
will open my eyes and I said you can
come back don't put an IV don't put the
blood pressure thing I said I don't know
what's going on right now but that [ __ ]
hurts don't touch me you put me in the
ambulance take me to hospital I said
nothing is to be done to me until I know
what the test is and what the outcome is
what the outcome that we want to be does
you see the future creates the present
this is another powerful thing that
conscious reality creation you must
engage the future that's why you have an
imagination so you can create something
and step into it you're bringing the
more real into an illusion in reality
creating so I had to take charge so when
they brought me into the hospital I said
who's in charge of ER said I'm in charge
that everything you do you tell me I
said I will create that the outcome is I
don't need to know what you're doing I
just need to know what do you need to
tell me when you get back that's
positive like will flow you that brain
down we think you got brain damage
you're having seizures and you got a bad
head trauma we're gonna put you CT scan
so has it gotta be just that's all I
need to know and then I don't remember I
was positive or negative when you come
out of this thing so I was okay so I
went in meditation the whole time I'm in
there I do work I knew how to do I come
out and they're like you're fine but for
sure you've got internal injuries you
know you totaled the car and the second
car is badly damaged and you know I was
like really I total and I remember
seeing the car I mean the whole thing
was slow-mo I was watching my whole body
go through the car just the whole car
was caving in like tin foil around me
and I was like laughing I was like what
I got this I was like just meeting the
car like like meeting it like okay this
is the hardest I've ever been hit and I
was I was laughing when I died because
when a car went around me I was like not
so bad then it snapped me on the hood
and I saw the hood just bend around me
and I was like no big deal I'm good I'm
good
and then the windshield hit me and it
broke so fast it didn't even hurt at all
and I was like I got this I got this and
then the roof caught my shoulder and it
just it flipped it just flipped me so
hard that I just I would just remember
laughing like oh that's the hardest that
I didn't even finish the thought but it
was that's the hardest I've ever been
hit you know I moved to LA to be a
stuntman I knew how to crash you know
and so it just it just was a whole
experience and so when I put myself back
in my body it tempered all the
constructs that I had already known I'm
like wow I just put myself back here I
don't know anybody that's done that I I
did that and of course now later I
realized you see your spirit is temporal
and non-temporal the masculine is
out of the feminine technically a lot of
people gonna give it God as a feminine
feminine energy it's not a masculine
energy that's the first thing I'll tell
you and it's not even a masculine energy
or a feminine energy alone
it was the goddess who created God and
together they create all that is that's
really what's happening and again so
many people in the wrong paradigm right
there they're in a chauvinistic
hierarchy there's them there's a
hierarchy going on here and it all boils
down to one no really boils all down to
zero zero being a representation of the
feminine but anyway that's another story
right so Rick Rick your your your your
your your sex it die
your experience is so crazy more intense
for a person like me cuz I'm like I
won't even take the time to argue about
and look I don't care think what you
want it's your reality believe what you
want I got no time to argue I'm only
want people that are understanding oh
there's something in that because I've
seen enough people now that get trigger
and go oh my god I just was listening to
you and I I know what you're saying and
those are the people I want to work I'm
at the front of the bell curve it's not
going to be a bunch of people understand
what I'm saying and then they don't have
to it only takes one person to change
the experience not eight million all
right let's let's see let's see what we
can do here yeah let's see what we can
do with this synthesis so alright so
when you when you you're oh by the way I
want to say this in the ambulance I told
him if you guys listen to me I will walk
out of the hospital in the morning
injury-free and they were like ok
Superman because I called that out I
told my wife the second day I went out
and I'm gonna marry you she's 22 you
know years younger than me I told her I
was gonna marry her and I did I told her
we're gonna have a boy and we did I told
her we gonna get prey on the first day
we tried we did I know how to create
reality in accordance to my will you see
that's that's the trick a cord means of
the heart your love and your will have
to be
balance in order to manifest it's not
your thought you thought you could think
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] all day and
nothing's gonna manifest unless you
emotionally connect to it now that's why
so many people live their fears their
greatest fears they matter my thing I
was the most afraid because you throw
that motion out there in the unconscious
mind and it just keeps generating
because you're not responding to it
appropriately so that unconscious
experience creates and manifests because
you're so afraid you got so much emotion
going into that you end up creating your
deepest fear but reality creation is a
process of thinking and feeling all
right let's let's let's see what we can
do here so it seems as though we took
this all the way back to when we come in
with the decisions into planet Earth
into the body that we choose right and
this is the idea that we're sitting here
with so many different people that say
this the spiritual thought of that we
get to pick our lessons we get to pick
our parents we get to pick all of these
other aspects our lessons our mission
all this our purpose all our stuff and
then we have the freewill the decisions
- like we said there's this possibility
space and then we get to collapse the
decisions that we want and we with
thought and feeling is how we kind of
identify what those possibilities are
and then we collapse it to the ones that
we give thought and feeling - more or
less there's a little bit of a thing
that people don't understand you see the
unconscious is massive your unconscious
mind it's not a consensus unconscious
it's your unconscious and so what's
happening is your subconscious creates
the three-dimensional structure for you
to exist in physical reality since your
subconscious is the part of your mind
that makes you adhere to your beliefs
because it's keeping possibility at bay
so your subconscious creates the
three-dimensional cube that your
experience lives in because though your
other lifetimes would just bleed through
and sometimes they do for some because
they're right there right on the other
side of the wall sometimes you
trying to push for a greater win in your
life and you're like it's right there
and I kind of got it but I didn't get it
that's because that possibilities
outside what's probable probability is
inside the cube actuality is inside the
cube possibility is outside the cube if
you don't learn to understand the cube I
put myself here how can I repay my self
if I don't understand what pot I'm in as
you get older
most the time conscious reality creation
doesn't really make sense to people hit
around 35 because they haven't had
enough of their patterns get hit enough
times where I realize when you're
younger you reframe when you go on to
something else
well I guess that wasn't the thing for
me and you can do that many times until
it doesn't work anymore and then you
realize wow I've I've never been able to
make more than $80,000 a year I don't
know why I just never because you had a
subconscious belief construct that says
that's what you've made your mind up
about money see if you don't know how to
alter that subconscious listens to you
exclusively a conscious self just like
American government is like the
president you're not really the most
powerful thing but you're the focal
point freewill and conscious choice is
that focal point subconscious is kind of
like the House of Representatives the
Senate is kind of like the unconscious
mind the people who designed our system
were brilliant
they they they mimic nature and freewill
in a system they knew what they were
doing so anyway I probably went a little
awfully ya know you're fascinating
there's so much still um yeah that's
yeah the the way that you're making
relations between even like a u.s.
governmental structure and the the
nature of our reality inside of the
vehicles that we that we take on it's
just crazy in the subconscious and and
also with yeah freewill and how we can
manifest and collapse into the the
futures that we want there's so many
things here there's so many things it's
so crazy there are so many things all
right and this is why it's so hard
letting someone go off because then I
have to try and go and crawl back and
find them versus interrupt them and
trying
like all right let's hit this one so
you're in this moment of just I don't
even know how to describe it how you're
feeling when you were in the accident
and then post accident or during
accident however it was that you entered
into this this whatever was happening I
don't even know what there's there's a
read there's the space-time and then
there's the in-between and then there's
what's not the physical reality and so
and so when you when you realize that
you were not even in them between the
way even beyond the beyond that that you
were the size of the physical universe
that had all the other millions of
universes in it and it was like the size
of a grapefruit and so rolling in the
living room so we are that and then we
are manifesting ourselves into the body
in the 3d world for less just for
finances not for even a lesson for fun
it's fun that's or the really you're
here to be fun and be successful creator
this is why God's not coming back
nobody's coming back because what's
happening is let's just say I've got and
I make you in my likeness in my image
and you have all like all intensive
person is my DNA is in you and I know
who I am I don't need to talk to you
anymore
I just co-created with you I enabled you
and I co-created for you to be an
independent spark of me I'm not coming
back because you screwed up and don't
know what you're doing you've got to
figure out who you are and that's the
process if physical reality there's so
much more consciousness outside of the
physical that'll never come here it's a
very small percentage of consciousness
even attempts to be physical because
it's super hard to do you on the other
side are the artists the artists the
cutting edge like people who are trying
to do something Craig right are the
people that are in physical experience
because they don't even know what a
straight line is outside of space and
time there are not holy and physical and
even there's nothing except what we make
as men in a straight line nothing in
nature is in a straight line that is
just a complete manifestation
of who we are here so the
uh-uh okay okay there's a there's still
there's still so many things okay let's
hit this one so you you should this felt
like five hours in the in the space but
in five years five years sorry sir five
years five years but it was 18 minutes
yeah and then when you when you when you
come back in you you you realize that
somehow that you that you're collapsing
your futures like as though the spirit
that you were had potentially left and
made side it died and that there was
room for another spirit to come yeah
okay ron has also had a similar
experience as well maybe this would be
an interesting time for you guys to to
talk about that if you want Ron well
Rick I was going to set myself on fire
later this evening but listening to you
I changed my mind you know you brought
me back to my senses but I didn't
experience anything as traumatic as you
you know it was it was induced by drugs
it could have possibly been a drug
overdose but I didn't um I didn't leave
my body it's J was it almost like just
getting zapped by a laser beam I I would
explain to people it felt like somebody
took out my old soul and replaced it
with a new soul and I live off of this
memory of Ron Vargas and I just I
reacted differently to so many so many
things I was more nor compassionate and
kinder and I and I and I and I and I
tried to keep my mouth shut as much as
possible so what you are saying is is
very refreshing number one because like
I might have I don't know I mean I lost
track this happened almost dodged Jesus
now 95 how long ago was that
what yeah 24 a right so you know since
that time it's still what's the word
blast with it but I'm just it's I'm just
blessed with a new me a new
understanding and this was in fact
deaths I did die I mean
whoever I was before this happened is
dead but I live off of him his brain and
but AJ was just maybe a step you know an
advancement I don't think I went behind
in any way but I was just I got a little
bit of a boost and I'm doing the best I
can with it I know that we're not alone
I know you know there's something bigger
than this 3d reality and I just can't
come right out and say these things as
eloquent as you can so listening to you
is refreshing it's like you know I
needed this this is also my imagination
too I need I need more people that
understand what I went through to help
me out and see here you are good to see
you and but you know I but on the same
note I'm at a point where jeez I want to
die again I want to die again I know but
I'm happy it's not I'm not unhappy it's
just I'm not afraid of death yeah and I
want to experience that death again and
I want to be young again you know I want
to have that that whole rebirth in the
new physical I want to be an infant
again so and I understand these are
possibilities he's not done with Rod
Vargas
I want the work to be done with Ron
Vargas - without a doubt well the best
way I can explain it is your soul is
eternal you always have the same soul on
all your lifetimes but your spirit
because the Spirit is the masculine it
is birthed out of the feminine you're
always connected to your soul to goddess
but the masculine is a connection that
is temporal and on temporal so when you
come into a new experience it's in
essence the masculine gets birthed again
so your spirit is different and that's
how you have a different name in every
lifetime because that's how you find
like that's how you can find yourself
again in essence like Oh Allen this
that's that has a specific resonance and
you can find that
but if that name has a an enlightened
experience in a way that you can
resource that again you don't have to be
born you could come back as Alan at 20
with a 90 year old wisdom you see now
you can do what you want you don't have
to be born and forget and go through all
that painful stuff you can come here for
a day go to Disneyland not wait in line
and have a good time and get out of here
that's what's possible once you can come
and go and so and that's what I'm
already myself playing okay what am I
going to do next time now that I likely
not going to come back to this
experience I've already done that twice
you know maybe I will but I I'm not
gonna know until I see a big picture
Rick can we be animals or is it just a
human experience you're past that
already is it works like this it's like
subatomic evolves into atomic evolves
into molecular involved into a mineral
involved into a plant involved into an
animal revolves into a human animal and
then a human being is the more advanced
stage of the human animal you can't tell
me dolphin to say no I wish I could surf
with them rather than surf along
I don't know oh well they can't get out
of the water that's depressing day I
mean there are beautiful consciousness
there's nothing to say and they're very
advanced consciousness but they're not
the pinnacle of nature we are we are and
the thing about it is since we are the
primary thing we if we knew that and we
knew how to operate we would be
supporting nature in every possible way
because the more we support nature the
more nature is going to support us right
now we're in a competition and a user
with a belief construct that everything
is a resource that runs out that's not
true the universe is always making more
of itself constantly there's no money in
this nature that can either but that's
the way that they're holding back on
that with with with losing fossil fuels
and going to go that's the adolescent
trying to stay control of the paradigm
that they want well when the [ __ ] you
they gonna grow up well as soon as
everybody else does it's your experience
right you cannot create a grown-up
experience if I cannot become one you're
going to create other adolescents that
you identify with and get into and
separate from the other people that you
don't like as long as that separation
keeps breaking up I mean if people know
divided you fall but the thing is they
don't know how to do it because the
adolescent doesn't know how to do it and
then I and the adult that knows how to
do it I don't even know how to get there
that's the primary thing I teach people
and I work with them is how to be an
adult and not the adult that the
adolescence is trying to avoid because
your parents didn't teach you what an
adult was either they were adolescents
raising children so you see it hasn't
really become like you know there in
indigenous cultures used to at a certain
age you would become you would go on a
Vision Quest and they would leave you
out in a jillion oh the jungle somewhere
and you'd have to find your way back and
when you found your way back they knew
you were a different person going
through that and you were treated as a
different print there was a demarcation
of where you were we don't do that
anymore
but we're more advanced now mm-hmm now
that has to be a conscious if you
haven't had a transformational court
let's say
adolescence is a transformation you go
from a child to an adolescent incident
chemical it's a gift
adulthood needs to be that same level
plus but it has to be chosen you don't
get a gift again the reason you get
wounded in adolescence is to for you to
get a taste of what it is to be a
powerful being and then your soul cuts
you off you get cut so deeply that when
I heal that cut I know I can heal
anything else and now I know how to move
forward with myself but as soon as I
don't cut that I never go to that level
it puts the top on the flea circus you
never go there again it's too scary too
painful and I've covered it up and so
they never fall in love again in a way
that they once were right so you you
miss all that power that power needs to
be reconfigured in the form of an adult
to be an adult is to be able to take the
naivete and the curiosity and the level
of forgiveness that a child has and
incorporate that in the adult that I am
to take the passion and the willfulness
of the adolescent incorporate in that
and an adult I am without the
stubbornness and without the
black-and-white dichotomies it's like
you must move yourself consciously into
a new position but how do I do that one
I don't know do you have to create a
space then you create a line and then
you step over the space and you have an
emotional experience that lets you know
that I'm over there or I'm over here and
then you start living an emotional
experience self generated self authored
by you the current person you can't you
will never be enlightened following
anybody's religious construct you'll
never be enlightened fall in what your
parents or you really you cannot do it
that way it must be a self authored
experience this is why I lied even
Buddha's like Buddha was enlightened but
why wars all the other enlightened
followers then if that worked
shouldn't there be thousands of them
there's not because it doesn't work it
may if even they existed worked for that
person but you cannot you can only give
a person the tools you cannot give them
the whole structure
to be self authored and so that's what I
guide a person into a new paradigm and
once you're operating there it feels so
good and you understand where the
character and integrity that I've been
so wanting how to have that and then you
realize oh I need to I know how I need
to see this I know how to take
responsibility for this interaction in a
way that's not a compromise or it's not
a way that I've already heard somebody
else do it's real time it's in real time
being an adult if you've got to go out
and think about what you're gonna say
before you say that's the adolescent
trying to look like I'm an adult I
better think about how I'm gonna say it
that's why if something with an
adolescent goes south and they they lose
their [ __ ] because they don't they're
not living from a set of values in real
time they're living from the past like
what do I do when this happens how
should I act when that happens what
should I say if a person says that you
see they're not in their life and that's
why the paradigm is breaking that cannot
continue anymore so only self authored
is the only thing you can do okay so we
trickle our way up over time from the
this subatomic to atomic to molecular to
neuro mineral to plant to animal to
human animal and then to human being
that's completely self oh yeah and then
now you're helping identify the tools in
this potentially sec the second spirit
that's coming to this body is helping
identify the tools for for the people
that you work with that can better
understand how to do the self authoring
practice but that self authoring is also
intricately woven with the collective
authoring well the collective you you
need to make sure you respond to the
collective appropriately and recognize
that's my unconscious mind it's still me
if everybody's over there arguing about
some student then that's I cannot
experience that unless I hold that
resonance you have to have a resonance
in order to experience a residence
because like right now we're sharing a
space
this relationship can't happen anywhere
else except right here the same thing as
anything out in the world if you're
dissing Trump and I go Trump look I
didn't vote for Trump but just to say
but he's our president now good bad or
ugly that's the icon for who we are you
must come to grips with what you don't
like that's part of your shadow what I
do like what is he you have to take that
apart and not separate from the idea if
you separate from that you're just gonna
be mad all day looking at something that
you think is outside of yourself when
it's a part of your spine that you've
stuffed away somewhere and it's showing
up in Trump if I keep separating from
that I can never have any impact on that
you see it's like conscious reality's
being conscious of how I'm feeling in
the moment where are those feelings
coming from my child my adolescent my
negative egos generating that you see
you can't really get rid of your
negative ego in conscious reality it's
an aspect of yourself the idea is to
function synergistically you have a self
eye and inner eye and an eagle eye and
between those two things that gives me
perspective if I were to kill my ego I'd
be dead it'd be like let's just poke one
eye out because I don't like what it's
looking at see the problem way everybody
has with their ego is their allowing
their ego to contextualise experience
when that's your choice
it can't actualizes do you agree because
you have a belief that it's using
against you you don't recognize that
it's just using my own belief to
manipulate me right now but it's my
belief that I forgot that I made that
decision and it's using it and I'm going
yeah [ __ ] those guys right
that's your negative ego it's
contextualizing instead of just giving
you the information the ego is supposed
to give you the information of physical
reality that's it not supposed to
contextualize just content if it's
contextualizing you're not in charge of
it you can't be in charge of it and
you're gonna be scared of it you're
gonna be worried about what it's
thinking like when you're trying to be
to bigger don't get too big for your
britches
that's your negative ego using a belief
against you to keep you small and you do
it because you believe it like I tell
people if you feel like a loser you're a
freakin loser
admit it you're a loser it's like oh yes
you're a loser if you hear it in your
mind you're a loser you're a loser
because you believe it and there's no
amount of rejecting that idea and
reframing that idea that's gonna turn
you into a winner you've got to change
that belief so that belief is not the
program anymore I'm a winner and you
just feel like a winner and you act as a
winner and if you're not you find out
why you see it must be self authored and
some people think oh my god it's so much
work what you're doing is so much work
out there so much painful work because
you don't need to grow through pain and
struggle you can grow through joy and
happiness and success it's just that we
haven't learned to do that because the
adolescent is so enamored with pain I'm
not I'm saying the the thought and the
emotion both Andry patterning our
beliefs they manifest the future
authoring that we want to set for right
and so then that's one of the tools
another one of them that you said was
this understanding of all of the traumas
the dramas all the things that are these
are these are sometimes the greatest
challenges that are put forth for us to
get through the adversity so that we can
find the greatest treasures the old
paradigm okay don't get through the
adverse what do you you you you you
recognize here's what conscious about
challenges here the challenge I'm gonna
struggle and fight against it and break
through it until and through it right
well if it's a subconscious pattern a my
subconscious that the reason that has
integrity is to just keep giving me my
program again and again and again it
isn't until you understand it's yours
understand how much pain have I gone
through and understand why I place
because when you're an adolescent and
you decide I'm never gonna love again
that hurt too much that's genius move
right there you shut yourself down and
you survive as an adult I can't be in
love I can't experience the depth of
what's possible for me as an unloved as
an adult it's a terrible idea
but you see like shame shame is a great
idea for a child to come up with I'm not
good enough that's why I don't have what
I want my parents aren't giving me what
I want because I'm not good enough well
that's I just have to learn to be better
and then you be better and you
survive because it's a terrible idea to
live with but it puts a pot it Mable's
me to survive and made it enables me to
grow but it only grows so far until now
that structure inhibits me but if I
don't remember oh I'm the one that
decided that I wasn't good enough I
forgot it was me what is our
relationship to the adversities that
those are your patterns that you've
outgrown like what I tell people in
conscious reality creating if you have
adversity or you have struggler you have
pain what you need to do is take that
apart now you need to understand what is
this pain telling me I walk people
through that it's harder to do it right
here because it's not a real pain so I
can't really direct through this but if
you said to me I have this problem and
it's constantly coming up I can walk you
through it what is yours what if she
says they'd have no problem then what do
you say if they have no problem I would
say so how do you what are you doing
with Trump let's just say forenski do
you have a problem with Trump and they
say no I don't have a problem so I would
just walk them through because here's
what a good say took we don't have a
problem that they are oh look they're
enlightened I would believe him if they
weren't aligned I would know they're
full of [ __ ] turn because you're
reframing if you don't know how to
change reality and quarters to your will
the only thing you can do is reframe and
you can cut enough stuff off and be this
monotone person like the Enlightenment
looks like this I don't get mad I'm
everything's perfect just the way it is
and the world is falling around apart
around you and that's coming out of the
garbage that you throw into your
unconscious mind your whole life hmm
so how could it be perfect if the world
is breaking down around me and I'm not
responding to that like not my problem
not my president not my I'm fine that's
denial hmm okay Rick how do people
achieve this state of awareness without
experiencing an nd8 well again you see
there's people that always hear me what
I'm saying and there's people that
always don't and so I only am interested
in the people that hear me do you know
what I mean it's like I don't want to
convince a person who's been a Catholic
for 40 years going to church that this
is the way that life they're it's just
too much struggle too much work it's
like it's the bell curve that you said
if you're an early mover on the bell
curve that you want to deal with other
people that kind of get it that you can
assist them with the pull-ups it's just
easier it's more elegant why do I want
to spend time arguing I don't care then
the Overton Window shifts over time and
then more and more people latch on okay
but but you want to at least understand
that belief precedes experience the
future creates the present this is why
Eckhart Tolle people drive me crazy but
that's it see this is attack that the
adolescent will use I'm too much anxiety
about the future it'd be better if I
didn't even think about it so I put the
future down because I don't know how to
utilize it properly so I put it down and
just try to be in the now and quit
worrying about it well the truth is a
human being all all all motivation comes
out of the future you do not have it now
is important because that's where choice
generates but all motivation now is
based on the future like if you get
hungry I have a question go ahead run
we're talking a lot about the future in
our imagination in molding our future it
my silly to also believe that by not
dwelling in the past but thinking about
my past that I'm altering my past do you
understand that question
yes it's not thinking about your past
that alters it but let's say if you knew
that time is an illusion like right you
kind of everybody knows it but the thing
is your child and your adolescent are
living breathing parts of yourself it's
not an exercise to go into a meditation
go into the past and heal something it's
real and because that past changes it
changes who you are and it changes the
future because you're working in three
dimensions you're in the now working
with the print the future motivates me
and the past is how I frame things you
don't even have a past unless I ask you
a question
and then you have to recreated created
minute I asked you and then so then one
of the things that you do then is that
you go with the person to buy that
moment in the past yeah question and
then the way that instead of that how
does how can the past serve the future
and that's kind of how does how does one
the future is the source of all healing
isn't it if you have cancer the only
reason you keep going is because you
have a hope that you're going to be
healed the people that die are the ones
that lose hope they don't they lose a
future old people die most of the time
because they stopped creating a future
I'm 80 what kind of I could die tomorrow
what I'm not planning anything anymore
I'm just living day to day you run out
of space when you don't keep creating a
future people I keep a garden they live
a long time just because the garden is
always growing and they're involved it's
a future they you must have a future all
the time and if you think you don't like
if people say I don't want expectation
for instance is a reality creation tool
people say I don't want to have any
expectation you still have a statement
that you must have a future all the time
yes that that is part of this future
authoring and it's so even just back
let's say almost 10 years ago when most
people are in the state for me about of
graduating in the high school era and
that they're trying to figure out what
they want to do and that even when
you're younger you're filling out in the
journals oh I want a future author my
soul to be this or in high school I
future myself to be that or when you get
to your first job oh I want to transform
to that but this is not a once every at
the beginning of the year at the end of
December at the beginning of January
this is a moment a moment this is when
you wake up in the morning you go to bed
at night that you're really connecting
to what you could become and knowing the
steps that you need to take to manifest
that to come true all you have to do is
take any step see what most people do is
they fantasize they don't take any
action toward the dream the minute you
here's the thing you live in this cube I
told you right well your dreams are in
the corners the minute you go after a
dream you're gonna hit your your
boundary immediately that's why I work
with people dreams I say we don't know
we'll work on the stuff
you're in pain about we'll move through
that but what I most want to work with
what's the dream you have for yourself
because the minute you go into the
corner of the cube you living you're
going to hit your resistances
immediately but you're going to be
moving because I'm going to help you get
through them and you're going to end up
moving toward a dream and you see once
you're moving toward a dream and you
realize the dream is just a bridge to a
destination that I don't have to
manifest a dream but it moves me in a
certain kind of way you see the future
is the source of all healing you're the
future of your child right now you're
the one that can go back there and help
them you're the only one that can go
back there and help them they're in real
time in pain somewhere and that's why
when you have a problem and you project
like somebody says something and you're
like let's say you were a fat kid once
and someone says hey fatty you go
that's not nice which cuz you're
projecting because the child and you
still remembers the pain of being fat
you never went back there and released
that child so it's that emotion from the
past is coming forward in affecting me
now if you unplug that there isn't
anything to affect you anymore you see
there's an elegance to that instead of
reframing and having to deal with that
again and again every time I hear
something about fat people I get all
weirded out that's because I haven't
dealt with that that's why when you feel
that you go there and you take it out
you don't just reframe it and reframe it
and reframe it you see so it has to be
something specific in order for me to
talk somebody through it okay let's
maybe Ron do you want to well let's say
why don't you give me something and then
I'll walk you through what conscious
area if you what like how here's the
problem or so our dream anything that
you're dealing with right now if you'd
want to talk about it I will walk you
through it you may not understand but I
can walk you through the system in a way
anything that I'm dealing with like you
said you were gonna burn yourself
tonight
now you channel that's part that's part
of it that's part of me yeah
I joke about that you know I don't fear
the death so I just I throw it out there
like there was a shooting earlier and I
texted my brother ah I missed a shooting
I'm sorry I wasn't in the
line of fire you know like I just can't
wait to you know to just to be done with
this this three ring circus because you
know I want to help but I'm and I can
only help immediately I'm limited with
my resources to help I don't there were
a bunch right there that's what I'm
saying you start yes please start okay
but did you see how many things that you
have programmed yourself this you're
basically it's a big problem and I don't
know how much good I can really do in
this problem but I'd like to do some
good because you were you were you were
contextualizing everything that you have
to live in that space that you're
defining for us right now that is the
space that you're living in because
you're giving it to us but the only
thing that's there are the beliefs right
now if I could go into a computer and
change those beliefs I wouldn't be
experiencing my experience at all that
way but you have to go in and take
responsibility for them all to them and
that's why I say yeah you
I can create any reality I want I can
have I've done many things that people
would be like oh you did that yeah
because when you start becoming self
author and you work on something
consciously and it changes like stopping
the oil leak and the bottom of the ocean
like and it stops when you did your work
you have to own that in reality I did it
yeah maybe a welder went down there and
play and I create the RIA but I'm the
one that went in meditation and came out
and now it's fixed you see you have to
start owning that because you are the
one and the more that you do that the
more your unconscious is the
subconscious go wow he's waking up this
is waking up it's not telling everybody
else to do things differently and accept
them and no you don't have to accept
anybody you don't have to like anybody
and you can still wake up it's just that
when you wake up you'll stop doing that
eventually because you'll recognize the
limitation that I experienced out of
thinking that way but it'll come in your
waking up you you can hate everybody the
first day you wake up and say I'm not
talking to anybody and wake up it'll
eventually you'll get to that belief
like well you know I want to engage
people because I want to love them and
so I need to drop that stuff that I hate
everybody now and you'll do it in your
time you don't have to do it all right
now or do the most important thing first
all you got to do is see a future so
keep going though because I just wanted
you to pay I am paying attention but
there now so I'm just to talk about my
month my boredom and in in my
understanding so that's that's another
thing I don't yeah how do you how do you
stay excited about this is this
understanding right because right now
it's like for instance if you've come to
the place where boredom is the most
emotion that I'm able to feel on the
daily and that's my norm my chronic
level is boredom that keeps you very
don't get me wrong it's it's a symphony
all the emotions it's an alluring
journey it's been a wonderful roller
coaster the ops the Downs to turn around
to twist the bends you know all right
well I wanted maybe just get on another
ride right
you know that's my another song yeah
down you got to learn to play the
instrument to play the song see right
now you have a song that's repeating in
yours tire of that song right and the
emotions of being tired of it are
supposed to give you the indicator I
have a limitation on myself if I'm tired
of something I am limited it's not like
when you have a kid and the kid is going
I want more I want more and you're like
I got to give you more I got no son
you're like that's the best I can do kid
you're gonna have to cry now you know
what I mean it's like you can only go
until you can go honestly if you force
yourself to go beyond what say that
again if I'm being in self-pity or you
be a martyr now you're a martyr and
you're angry at your kid you're jerking
them around because they won't shut up
because you're getting mad because
you're of lack of patience you're the
one that has a lack of patience the kids
just doing their thing I need patience
well I mean that's your finishing
thought in this 3d reality now let's see
I know it's got it but you know it's
vent to the adolescents patience is
waiting to the adult patients is fully
focused on the moment waiting for it to
happen the way I want it you see a cat
is patient do you ever see a cat hunt a
bird they go out there and then BOOM
that's patients most people like I've
been waiting oh that's not patients
that's the kid not not focused on what I
want reality to give me right and so if
patients definition is waiting not
patience that's not patience it's
waiting but I use patience in it then I
never go to patients I never understand
what patience is I never understand how
to utilize what patience is patience is
a very willful act it is not a passive
waiting it's like I'm gonna be patient
okay so I want what I want like my wife
I told her second day we're together I
said you know what I'm gonna tell you
this because I'm giving you a gift right
now it's like I'd like to give you I'm
gonna tell you that I'm 100% on with you
you don't have to be don't worry about
anything I'm saying I'm just letting you
know I'm 100% on I called the five girls
I'm dating right now cuz I'm dating five
I told them I can't date them anymore
because I'm into you you do what you
want you see if this feels right if it
doesn't feel right tell me and I'll drop
it because in reality creating you have
to go through your subconscious into the
unconscious back through again so this
your measuring device is that
subconscious it's going to feed you your
belief if they say no you know what does
you're not really my type then you go
well let me ask some questions would you
mind go what does that mean that I'm not
your type not so I can convince her of
something else in control because I want
to know what my beliefs are you know now
that I it was important to me and I put
myself out there and I went for it
because I'm at the edge of my cube I'm
gonna get the feedback immediately on
what my beliefs are so you don't get mad
and I can't believe you say what a [ __ ]
you know whatever you just go okay thank
you for being honest now can you tell me
something more like what are you feeling
about what I said you know because I'd
like to learn from this because I was
really feeling something and I wanted to
act on you see what I mean that's what
conscious reality looks like you need to
understand yourself better through the
impact of another you're having impact
on everybody else but everybody has
their own universe and since if you have
a really strong belief it'll show up
like lots of people believe that
everybody believes this that's just an
unconscious belief construct because my
own conscience is more vast than my
subconscious and so if everybody agrees
that's just a really solid belief all
right let's try and hit this from
another side of this let's try and hit
it from the from the future authoring
side where what is being we've didn't
really get to I know that's okay I
wanted you to hear already you can hear
him talking about the beliefs that just
came boom boom boom boom that set the
stage for him to say this is what it is
for me yeah there's there's probably no
time that is better for what I feel with
Ron then when Ron is just in his flow he
is just doing what he loves and you can
see him he is a child loving what he's
doing and then you can see him in the
way that he was just speaking I can't
sue harder so yeah that's the same child
it's just the other side the negative
aspect of what it is to be a child
disempowered I can't change anything I
have to get permission for anything at
all that is the mentality of the child
coming through the adult because right
now if you're not an awakened adult you
can only operate from child and
adolescent I can only operate from those
two places until I have a new place to
operate from what am I gonna do about a
dark adversary did you know that I'm
aware of
how do i how do I lose that how do I
beat that how do I not pay attention to
that
how do I you know it's it's it's it's
real to me it's a real it's a real being
among us that just want to shut that's
the back side you have to be able to now
again if you don't want to say that no
problem but how are you going to get out
of that if you don't if you don't find a
way out of that and being everybody
knows reality is an illusion everybody
knows it's being observed by me I mean
there's plenty of science that's already
told you enough to understand that I
have to some
take responsibility for myself is like
when I work with people I've got people
often I can get people that have been on
depressive drugs done in 60 days no more
and never go back because when you find
out why are they going after the drug
and you up like that they don't need it
anymore and it just ceases to exist it's
like I've worked with alcoholics I say
okay start drinking and then I what I'm
like yeah I got to know why you're
drinking and as long as you're in this
framework and resisting and thinking
it's bad and I'm never gonna do it I've
got 186 days I haven't done it and
you're not going to find out why you're
doing it so just lighten up and have a
drink and let's see what happens and
then they can get through it it's like
but if you can't respond to it in a
powerful way you're never gonna change
that so first off you'd have to say do
you really want to change that adversary
do you want that to go away because you
may not care but if you say I really
want that to go away then the first
thing we'd have to say is what are your
beliefs around this adversary because
we've got to get in there and unplug
everything that's making it a good I
don't want to be naive I don't I wanted
to I don't want it to go away you don't
want it to go away so you you because I
think in allowing it to go away I deny
that that a negative darker side within
me that it's like a monkey on your back
as something that that you know it needs
to be beat aren't you denying it now am
i denying yeah like there's this
adversary out there that I know is there
and I don't want anything I'm trying to
avoid it at any cost isn't that denial
that's it sounds ex acknowledgement to
me but then what are you doing with it
right okay it's there now what are you
doing it loves me yeah I'm an anomaly
you've got to take it apart if it's like
mechanics if the car you don't know
anything about the car and you pull in
my shop and I hear a click I'm like
that's the valve and the eight cylinder
position I can hear it they're like what
I know just what needs to be done I can
hear what you're saying and I know what
needs to be done but it's like it may
not you may not understand any of it so
you may either follow what I'm saying or
not do you see what I'm it's like
if it doesn't make sense or it scares
you and you don't want to go into it
then that's fine but you that's why it
has to be a real problem that you want
to end I'm fine let's wrap up the show
go have a drink and get high see these
are the things that come I've had a
decent amount now of mentors that I
think are onto something when they help
me dive deepest into what you're
describing and I think that that those
moments have been some of the most
profound of my life is really digging
deep into Who I am why I behave in
certain ways why those patterns are
there this type of thing whenever it's
really hard to get to with wrong it's
really hard but that's a limiting belief
it's easier it's easy to get to with Ron
it's just that I don't know well that's
a reframe it is a reef the first one was
your belief yeah if I can't go like
literally go into the computer and take
that out and put in something good I
can't just reframe it on the outside
because really my emotional Center is
connected to it's really hard to do with
I want to figure out how and I will
figure out how is that a better that's
yeah I will figure I won't run to have a
better life and I guess I have to see
him in a better way I have to see him in
a better way yeah and that starts you
into conscious reality creation because
if you really want to see him in a
better way and that meaningful to you
now what does that mean better in what
way now let me you'll you'll pursue it
and you'll start real recognizing all
the limited beliefs you have once you
get there and you understand wow I got a
lot of limited beliefs as I got to
forgive myself that I've been holding
Ron and this I mean I'm just saying it
this way I've been holding him in this
regard for so long and yeah and I have
to forgive myself for that because I
didn't realize I was doing it you see
it's like it's a process it's healing as
a process right so I know the mechanics
I can hear what's going on and go right
in there but a lot of people people do
it what's that tool do I'm like don't
worry about that tool I'll give it to
you when you need it but it's like at
first they just need to be able that's
why people under 30 it's hard for them
to get this they haven't even had a full
cycle to themself yet really see what my
patterns are those patterns those see
diving into the patterns are so crucial
I was trying to mention this earlier and
maybe we can do this again with another
conversation but with Ron and you and
stuff but and myself but on on a really
for something that the audience may also
be able to attribute to something that
they do on a daily basis this idea
future authoring well can we set forth
who we want to be in a future
possibility space and can we collapse
our daily activities and our habits and
reframe and make new patterns and our
behavior to be able to achieve that of
which we want that's exactly what I
teach all of that that's exactly what I
do but you see it's like because
everybody's an individual it needs to be
passed on verbally I need to get
intimate with the person that's working
with me and they got to trust me and
then at first everybody gives you the
first things that they kind of want to
work on but then after you get deeper
you realize there's a lot more painful
stuff that they didn't quite trust me
yet with and then boom it starts [ __ ]
paying a Bam Bam because now they're
like this guy is trustworthy and so now
I can take you when you feel it's not
until you open up to me when it really
happens in the meantime you're growing
and changing and getting but there'll be
a point when all sudden it clicks and
you recognize what's going on between
you and I and then you start growing and
the thing is it's like that's where
enlightenment lies you have to know who
you are to be enlightened once you're
enlightened once you know you're a god
being creating everything 100% it's just
a belief that belief eventually isn't
going to serve you either but for right
now it's pretty big and would really
solve a lot of things because any
structure in our universe that expanding
is going to eventually limit you that's
what I'm saying when you were a kid you
came up with this idea of shame
that was being dumped on me by my family
and then I incorporated it in myself and
used it as a tool at that time it got me
through a lot of pain and today it's
crushing me it's crushing me today
because you didn't realize I put that in
unconsciously so now that I understand
that I put it in I can understand how I
can take it out and I can put something
better in and you know your your image
of yourself is the same thing you have a
cube that you function as Alan and a
cube and everybody has but when you can
learn to identify that cube with
processes and go I know with this cube
is now I know how to move it out
possibilities just start happening you
don't have to do anything else
conscious reality creation is always
self empowered self authored you don't
you utilize experience for the illusion
that it is something I'm generating that
I'm connecting with this is the realm of
possibility I came in here as a spark of
consciousness and it conformed to what I
Who I am and it long and once I get that
and once I start the first couple times
you change something you're like oh my
god it's the easiest thing ever to do
and then you realize everybody's doing
it but they're literally doing it
backwards right now that's why it's so
painful you know you don't want to go
downstream without a rudder you can't go
up string without propeller either for
the most but you know what I mean you've
got to have some way people like I just
want to go downstream not without a
rudder you know what I mean you still
need to direct you need to self author
and so people are guy just want their
piece I just want to be hard I just want
to be one again you're never gonna be
one again when you decided you and God
has decided you were going to be an
individual spark of who they were you
never go back to oneness again you are
now a god being you are one with
yourself and everything else is me and
everything else is everyone else you set
it up it's not a logical thing I go so
where everything is just part of my mind
and I can treat it like I want no
because you also have impact on
everything around you so you can feel
what love does and what it doesn't do
see so there's an impact it's not just a
logical thing well then nothing matters
it's just I could do whatever
that's the adolescent taking it in the
wrong direction
you know the God being I wanna you we
can start rapping with the God being
just that you speak about this we become
we mentioned this a little bit earlier
but the greatest potential is our
imagination we were talking about the
future our greatest tool the greatest
tool is our imagination and then with
this God being this fully self authored
experience you also teach people and I
think this is super applicable to all of
us is there are relationships with love
with intimacy with money
yes teach us about that well again if
everything I say if but because I this
way everything is a reflection of your
unconscious mind and everything is a
program so you don't realize one time
your dad came home with a check when you
were a kid and it said $1,200 on it and
you were like fire like well I could buy
anything with that and that was a lot of
money but you don't realize that was
that one little moment that I don't even
remember anymore
was what generated the space that I can
create money in and there generated the
cube yeah there's a cube that you you
made a belief that day like wow that's a
lot of money and since you were feeling
a lot when you were like wow it's so
cool that that's all it takes to program
the subconscious the program what the
subconscious is looking for is an
intense emotion followed by a thought a
direct thought as soon as it hears that
program an intense emotion followed by a
thought and we just go that's why
adolescence programs the [ __ ] out of
you're in so much pain and you're
feeling things you never felt before and
you're and you're smarter now so you're
using logic and reason to dictate
everything around you and you're just
trying to make choices in order to get
through it but you're programming the
[ __ ] out of yourself
and so later you're living that you know
you're just living all the programs that
you weren't aware of because nobody told
you what you were doing so then we need
a sniff our way back somehow to that
moment to see the edge of them well
because you repeat so many moments they
all have the same structure you just
need to find the same feeling anywhere
you don't the first one is the most
intense but your subconscious is just
feeding it throughout so anyone can do
it okay anyone that you could feel
intensely you can go back to any love
intimacy or money moment any pattern any
part of that code that helped yeah and
then you can really can reprogram
reprogram it you've got a big you know
that's part of what I teach is I teach
them what the subconscious is and then I
teach them how to personify it in
meditation and that way you can go there
and you have a relationship that builds
in the more real you see in your mind is
more real than this because your mind is
generating your experience let's say if
I say you like brownies and you're like
I love brownies your mouth starts
watering right because your internal
world doesn't know the difference that
it's really not here so when you go into
meditation and you imagine something
going on your entire brain and your
being does not know it's not real this
is just getting electrical impulses back
to the brain to give but if you close
your eyes and give yourself the same
impulses it's the same thing so when you
start building a relationship in
meditation it's more real than anything
out here because you're in you're in the
model now people don't know that they
don't realize meditation is a key
element in order to consciously create
this is what for instance with athletes
when they go in and they visualize
making the game when it shot and then it
happens
they just program their subconscious
that way but imagine if I had a living
breathing thing that I had a name and I
had a body for it I said dude I need to
do this and I call I know where that is
let's go get it and you go in there and
you reprogram it right in the spot
there's techniques for that to be able
to do it and in your reality will be
different when you come out if it
doesn't you just miss something and you
need to do it again but when you do it
don't be another piece of information
that you'll find out about because now
you're watching you're watching the
feedback if I go into a meditation and I
change something when I come out it's
gonna be different if it's all the way
different great high five if it's half
way different why is it half there must
be another piece in the equation that I
need to recognize in order to own
because when the child may adolescent
have made all these decisions they
really took all your power away
the only way you're gonna get all that
power back to be you know I children
they forgive like that you can screw out
there we forget yeah I forgive me move
they're in love with you again just like
that right to be that person you need to
get that strength back and it's behind a
negative belief so you you bring the
process of reprogramming into meditation
yes okay and then what am I doing with
my meditation practice in order to
reprogram well first off I teach you a
meditation practice that begins that
process like a lot of people like into
trance and Transcendental Meditation is
a waste of time
it's just a waste of time because why
are you getting centered to be all
peaceful and quiet
for what with no end if I'm going to go
into the peace and into the harmony into
the dark hush that beautiful hush that
you're looking for I'm going to ask for
something while I'm in there and come
out and see if I got it if you just get
there and sit there it's like sitting in
the car with it running and not putting
it in gear everything is working and I'm
just gonna sit in here this is awesome
it's the same thing you're not really
taking your gut beingness and utilizing
the center position it's like doing this
it's like I get centered but I don't
jump I just stay in there you want to
get to a point where I'd leap free you
see nobody's doing the next step that is
get down in there this is great I'm not
freaking out right now
yeah but now you're in this beautiful
hemant this beautiful feminine space you
want to ask for something and see if you
get it see if you can receive it your
life is a gift and all you're really
here to do is receives a gift that's the
only reason you're here your life is a
gift and all you're here to do is
receive the gift that's it if you're
willing to receive it and willing
willing is a focused willful Act
receiving is not I'm going to receive
today yeah receive what Oh anything into
getting into the deepest meditative
States and then asking for that future
authoring for ya to co-create to
co-create so you so there's both the
process of reprogramming and co-creating
so they're co-creating is what does the
reprogramming know know that go creating
you are you must always be self authored
you let's say if I'm God and I know
you're perfect I'm not gonna interfere
with you the universe doesn't conspire
for you it's just a reflection it's
everything about it as a reflection for
you by you it's like it's not doing
anything to help you it's not it's not
therefore that it's only there to show
you who you are who are you what are
your beliefs that's it it's only
conforming to the person observing and
it's you're observing all the stuff
you're unaware of right now once you
take that out then you start realizing I
want to create everything that I'm
observing I want to be responsible for
that stuff because it's fun it's fun and
it makes life elegant there's an ease
there's a complexity to it it's not
complicated but it's complex so it's
like I first I do I teach them what
meditation is how to utilize meditation
in a powerful way now how do how do I
build a relationship with my
subconscious these are all things that
we work on week to week you know that's
why I touch base every day with my
clients every day they journal to me and
then I see what was important what
didn't happen
because if they journal they have to
make a really willful choice of what
they're gonna talk about today hmm
and now I could see their program and
say notice this is oblique notice this
let's change this and see what
this does when we change this and so I'm
holding their hand while they navigate
reality and watch it changed in
accordance to their will so the
journaling of what the clients can give
you a deep insight into their limited
Leafs into how much their future
authoring the more they share the better
the information is more that because the
intimacy starts happening you see people
avoid intimacy because when you're
intimate
that's where magic happens that people
are terrified of magic so they avoid
intimacy to stay away from the magic
because when you're intimate that thing
is gonna change you
I love intimacy magic [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah okay let's let's um we have so much
more to talk about on another round soon
Rick let's um let's ask you a couple
quick questions no I know just for you
if you want to go and you want to have
more to edit because it's choppy you
know I'm fine to stay we could talk and
you can totally totally add some we'll
figure it we'll figure out what to do
Ron's Ron wants to roll was that true
Ron well we just don't edit yeah we
don't use eyes all livestream but the
point we don't have the budget to you
know take little bits of these so we're
they're viral where we know people have
a short attention span you know these
four hour marathons
there's just no money in them yeah
there's a lot of nuance to it Ron
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about
hahaha there's um there's a ton of you
know you're right but there's lots of
things you don't know what the [ __ ] you
talking to baby all right so let's let's
let's wrap this one and then we'll be
able to we'll be able to unpack more on
another time as well okay let's do first
question is are we alone in the cosmos
No aren't we here together the cosmos is
your calibrate to see the cosmos as it
is the cosmos is just possibility and
then you create the planets and all the
things going on you're the one that's
already doing that so yeah of course you
can have aliens and all kind
if that's what you want if that's what
you want to play with I'm to me I like
to what end why do I want some aliens
here so they can come and give me some
technology because I can't figure it out
myself I don't think so not for me I
want to figure it out I want to be a
conscious reality crater yeah I don't
want people [ __ ] on here and fix the
problem that's part of my journey that's
part of the reality you're creating that
there's X amount of problems out there
and what are we gonna do about it
well I'm only one person if you have all
those beliefs there's nothing you can do
about them but if you had a belief that
I could do something and I'm enjoying my
process on one on one and I'm just
watching it do its thing you'll enjoy
the process and it'll change everything
when it does when you can receive that
it does it's a whole process going on
because once you understand how to
consciously create reality you move into
being a receiver but not without
direction not just a receiver
you know I'm directing what I'm
receiving and that's what's magical
about it because I said when X&Y came
and it was better the next in the first
place and I could see how it happened
and that was awesome
and now it's fun because it's this or
better or what you're creating not this
is the best and maybe something less you
see first that's how everybody creates
because they're creating from your least
best self you're creating reality right
now from resistance only that's why pain
is the first thing everybody wants to
work on because that's the most dense
part of who they are at this time when
you open to something beautiful now the
most dense thing is something I'm
contributing to that's beautiful self
authored and now that thing is
generating a reality with me that makes
sense mm-hmm
joven the most kindergarten way possible
they were starting to unpack and
understand it better how about are we in
a simulation well again why would I
believe that I'm in a simulation of it I
couldn't be a god being if I'm gonna
believe that right and again beliefs
just to be clear a belief is an opinion
you hold with conviction that's it it's
not real and it's not based in fact
almost never people just got us that's
it they make a decision you know they
say most people
political affiliation comes from their
fourth grade fourth grade they decided
what political affiliation they were
gonna be you see they don't realize it
all that pain in the past unconsciously
generating all this pain right now
because people aren't healing it they're
trying to deny it so that they keep
stuffing it in the back and it just
keeps getting louder and louder and
louder you see so that's where the
response and so what's going to happen
is the reality is gonna split like it is
there's gonna be people living a dream
and people living in nightmare and they
won't even know each other anymore
that's what's already starting to happen
but they call it 99 one-percenters it's
splitting and since most people don't
get their dream the people that belief
think it's 1% of the people are getting
what they want that's not fair that's
what you're creating you're being part
of the 99 you know if you were one of
the one-percenters you wouldn't want to
be given all your money up for them to
99 percent unless you're not unless
you're an adult and you're like let me
use it but now they're like let's force
those people to give up their money
because they've been hoarding it that's
just the adolescent getting pissed off
and try to control somebody else
he's like well when their money runs out
then what are we gonna do I'm gonna take
all the money from the rich people then
what happens it gets distributed $5
everybody gets $5 in the world's
different place it's like it says that
does model doesn't really work it's just
angry model its angry and feeling like I
don't have enough and I'm not getting
mine and they're getting theirs and
there's such a disparity now because
there's essentially disparity and then
the ability for people to dream they're
not imagining anything except the worst
they don't know they're creating reality
that way it's harder to imagine
everything happening beautifully it's
easy to imagine everything going to [ __ ]
and so they're just doing what's easy
and they're creating a reality
and then what would you say is the most
beautiful thing in the world beauty
itself I you know beauty itself does
just that
just beauty you know it's like what's
beautiful to me is an awake person like
honestly awake not just the white got
[ __ ] and I'd ride a bike and I
don't eat any meat and I don't that's
not a wolf person that's an adolescent
trying to figure out all the right
things to do and living that way and not
being happy about it
being mad at the people in the car being
mad at the people who keep eating me
being mad at all these people that are
doing what I feel is not right you just
feel like it's not right it's a belief
and you're acting on it not realizing
that you could change that right now I
mean when you know how and so at first
it's a little daunting it's like oh my
god dude in three months everybody's so
different they don't even three months
three months different person and you
never go back you don't go backwards I'm
not gonna be a dog I've already passed
that point you you just start operating
in a way and you know how to do it and
when you know how to do it you don't get
thrown off it's not like you go back
sometimes you might go back and but
you'll realize oh well what if you say
you can't go back being a jog and I'm
imagining that you're wrong and you can
be then I can also alter that reality
without a belief that you want to burn
yourself and get out of this there we go
know what I'm just saying your belief
construct right now for your in your own
and your own from your own self or your
own person is let's just say
energetically I can feel there's pieces
of yourself that have been defeated and
you don't know what to do with that yeah
well if I died you should get bit by a
dog one of these days I want you to
think of me and take a good look in the
eyes
Rick this has been such an epic episode
I've had a blast talking to you oh good
really enriching I know it went kind of
you know wherever it went but it was
really good it was really good I
appreciate you coming home you're
welcome thank you for having me yeah we
greatly appreciate it's been a pleasure
huge shout out to Ron Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ron we appreciate it glad you got
to chime in on the things that you and
Rick got have similarities on that was
interesting hearing you guys talk
Hugh Schatz everyone for tuning in thank
you we would love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode
also go and talk more with your friends
your family your co-workers people
online on social media about these
conscious reality creators how we can
beat them ourselves how we are these god
beings authoring our futures check out
the links in the bio below to conscious
reality creator calm the Paris principle
calm and Rick's LinkedIn profile check
out all those links also support the
artists entrepreneurs the organizations
around the world that you believe in
support them help them grow help
simulation grow our links are below as
well and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
[Music]